so you guys we're doing a new version of
logotherapy we're going to be only
talking to one designer moving forward
so that we can go deeper and have more
conversations and provide some critique
as well which we haven't been able to do
in the past joining me today is a very
young guy he's originally from Iraq and
he is now residing in Ankara Turkey and
this is who he is his name is Omar
Soliman you guys can check them out on
behance at Omar 3 to 4
Omar 3 to 4 and when you arrive there
you'll see some of his work and what
we're doing is we're tackling this mark
which he selected himself and he's gonna
be redesigning now and moving forward
our regular logo therapists are gonna be
taking famous logos and redesigning the
logos that you hate the logos that you
love to hate basically and can't
complain about so we're gonna see how
they do what would they do to fix those
logos okay so that's what we're doing
here so why don't we take a look at
share your screen with this all Myron
shows your your project set up and then
take us through a little bit more of
what you're doing I could barely hear
you can you just grab the mic and just
put it right next to your mouth I could
barely hear you know what I'm a yes
better I also and I do the same
different ways like also different
shapes this logo creation
using I focuses here on the patterns of
the character like also if this for for
and there are four cycle also just this
line of the antibody yes and I tried to
make the ball small to be like balance
and I use cotton ratio just a part Hey
and this is Debbie and you see we have
like I take it and put it here this
spacing between the okay that's a nice
little touch because the archer doesn't
have an arrow so to sneak an arrow into
the negative the counter of the V that's
a neat little idea there oh my god it's
also something I won't show today Dennis
maybe you can't helpful for contact
local and sometimes you see the text but
it doesn't connection I always use
coordination and if you use the right
font after you can use this like the
site I contain and speak for me I
actually like the horizontal lock up
more than the vertical lock up because
for some reason it feels a little bit
more balanced to me do you have one
where
can see the horizontal lock up without
all the other grid lines on top of it
I'm just curious
sorry yeah yeah sure you know the third
one that you did the horizontal logo
lock I white on black somewhere okay
okay I'm just here for you okay yes
we'll get to that later
are there other things you want to show
it okay just continue this dark version
of this this is family
Monserrat which is the Sun strike font
it's clean and I think it's appropriate
for this logo and this prong so I select
it and this is the color palette I I
select the cold color wither and t-step
primary work on the white on the also in
the black it is good thing and I like
you and I want share some linkages you
can taste the contrast for color this is
the site of the for taste contrast I put
color here and right yep white and you
know like I say I can see it's a a large
does mean I can use it but if if we like
selected with this color it is people
like he writes feel like can you use
this it's very wait go go back to that
go back to that what site is this that
you're looking at something new to me GX
and B okay
okay I I can't see that from here so
Jonah or Mark and you guys drop that in
the comic oh you already did that okay
colorable okay that's neat little tool
stay on this one with the beginners for
a second can you go back no we got it we
figured it out
go back to your yeah I just want to talk
what what go back go back
yeah to stay here I really liked how you
resolve this logo icon the symbol and
how you found variations to it and I'm
not sure how they would use this as a
system but for me I really liked the one
on the far left against the blue
background I think it's really dynamic
and how he's pulling back this string of
the bow and looking up I think that's
really cool
icons 2 3 & 4 pretty cool I countries a
little strange it feels like he's doing
one of these things like uh you know I'm
talking about
check me out so that one's a little
strange
yeah it's like hey it's Friday alright
so I like that there's variations to
your icon pretty cool meow my birthday
[Laughter]
go back one page okay I liked it better
when the arrow is implied versus being
just in the shot I like it as a
background element I'm not sure I love
it like as an element right there my
suggestion would be
to imply that the arrow is there by
creating a black shape like a very thin
black line across the background like we
can't see it but we can see that it's
leaving a black negative space do you
know what I'm saying like the trail of
the arrow yes okay okay let's you've
gone nicely animates I want to
appreciate this a little bit longer I
guess now I understand why there's that
one like boom
check me out ladies I'm here BAM okay
because now it's like I'm gonna shoot an
arrow I'm gonna party blue it's Friday
and then check me out okay keep going I
see you may get some me on the Friday
night file yep nice that's where the
bathroom is yeah oh wait go back go back
okay I just want to quickly comment here
I think this is one of those
opportunities where things line up just
really well for you for example the one
on the right where he's seeming like
holding up a very heavy object I like
that the one where he's shooting the
arrow up to stairway I think if you
scaled that guy down and lined up the
handrail with where that arrow would
have been I thought there's an
opportunity there so you're using the
objects in the environment and you're
being very playful within it okay keep
going
this is this card this from top of you I
put my personal information here
tomorrow night and it's funny funny
strategy yeah okay that's it okay so I
have to focus only on the shape I don't
know you make it already yes there's
good to see this now I want you to go
back to your letterhead identity system
I have some comments and some critique
here for you people have been asking me
to to weigh in and not just have people
present but to give also some opinion
and critique so I'm gonna use this
opportunity now that we're focused only
on one person presenting at a time so go
ahead to your letterhead yeah is it can
you zoom in on just a straight shot
please the next the next frame
no the other letterhead one the one
we're just straight on so we can look at
it it's a little easier to look at not a
name
the one not at an angle the next one no
no go to the next one next frame nope
forward forward please okay not this one
next one this one no no the identity
system that's the straight okay okay
language language communication issue
everybody hang in there okay no the
letter the letterhead please just go
back one this one this this yeah no this
I I give up I give up going over a head
resume and business cards not this one
the next one please
from Tokyo are snobby we help you please
okay next yes I give up it's okay
we're just this one yes please stay here
okay there's a couple things I wanna
talk about okay he's done a good job of
creating a logo where I think you
probably wanted to spend a little bit
more time here
Omar is to really think about the
typography and how it's used
okay I think a lot of logo designers our
logo designers for a reason and then
typographers so topographers for a
reason and what we want to do is bring
those two worlds together when we're
designing an identity system I can tell
right now that there's some hierarchy
issues like when you're talking about
the front side of the business card I
don't think the arrow should be as big
as it is because that's where my eye
goes first and I really want to see your
mark if anything I would scale down your
type and make the mark the hero or kind
of resolve this because it feels like
I'm looking at 1 2 3 4 5 groups of
information and at most I want to see 3
I think you resolve that nicely on the
right hand side there when you just make
the icon and the
lock up where it's the white on the blue
I think you might have changed this from
your previous exploration or maybe I
just remember it differently but I think
if you everybody can just stare at the
blue business card the backside of the
business card I think it'd be really
nice to have the service MVP move north
like move it up so that the negative
space between service and MVP that lines
up where the arrow should shoot through
I hope I'm describing that so you guys
can see that and perhaps if Omar has a
minute there he can pull that up later
and show us the business card and move
that up and you might see that it would
line up a lot nicer now when I look at
the letterhead can we pan down a little
bit so we can see all the letterhead
please just pan down a little bit yeah a
little bit more okay okay that's fine
okay now I can tell right now that
whoever did this never use this
letterhead and I'll tell you why the
width of the textbox is too wide there's
too many words in there so usually when
you're typesetting you're reading I
don't know what the ideal character with
this but it's this is too far like
there's too many words on a line and as
we're reading from left to right we're
going to lose our place the other thing
is you're going to want to use a lighter
cut of montserrat so that it doesn't
compete with everything like right now
it feels really heavy and dense and when
when I was taking identity systems with
my professor at Art Center he would
always say print it out write a real
letter and sign it and use it and then
you will start to see where there your
system breaks down so for me right now
it should have an address it should have
for the from who it's sending to what
it's regarding it probably has a
signature line etc so it looks real so
if you do this your mock-ups are going
to look very professional and
communicate to somebody like this is
real alright and I think when you're
designing the rest of your envelope I
think that's an envelope the front and
the back of the envelope is that what
that is Omar
not right there is that the hedge of
wire yes okay flyer and then the bottom
is an envelope right yeah okay so
there's a flyer there a lot of fliers
like this are probably gonna want to
have a lot more space for copy and
images where the icon the logo might
want to be a lot smaller so if you
create a flyer like this everybody's
gonna have to redesign every single time
because there's not a lot of space to
work with so what I would do is in your
system maybe make the icon system
because I'm seeing two icons the the guy
with his arms by his ears and the archer
at the bottom right corner maybe just
reduce it and simplify it so that
there's a lot of other creative ways
that people can use the system and
that's what we get into when we're
talking about system design designing
for a lot of different purposes and
applications the envelope itself to me
again probably has a lot a lot going on
here I would just encourage you to
simplify put a return address on there
and call it the day we don't need to see
so much the arrow the guy with his hand
in the air and the archer in the bottom
right okay
now let's let me take a few questions
and Omar while we're doing that can you
try and play with the archer and the
horizontal lock up and move the tight
service MVP up so that the neck the
space the letting between service and
MVP line up with where the arrow should
go through okay
can you work on that for a little bit
Omar okay you understand what I'm saying
okay then I'll walk you through it so
why don't you get that file up and then
we'll we'll keep talking so go to the
one where the service MVP is next to the
icon where it's anything a business card
or the name and anything that you have
okay while you do that I'm gonna answer
a few questions so three b8f a are asks
how do we participate in the logo
therapy session you just reach out to me
you send me some of your work you tell
me what you want to do
and if I like what you're doing we'll
feature you okay
there are some requirements that I can
see now why in the past we've had
certain restrictions or while we're very
selective with who we invite on the show
because yeah you have to have a good
camera a good microphone good internet
speed and that's gonna eliminate a lot
of people just off the bat because we
want to we want to see you we want to
hear you okay so Omar's opening up his
file he's working on that so that's how
you do it and moving forward I want to
do logo redesigns and not just of any
logo but a famous logo so if you're
watching this live stream go ahead tell
tell us the logos did you think are
atrocious the ones that make your skin
crawl and drop them down a big company
so that we know what you're talking
about
and you can make suggestions and future
guests will be able to look at that list
and say yes I'm gonna take that one on
because everybody hates that so much I
see in the chat people are not very
happy with the new BMW logo there
they're making some questions about
Nissan needing a new logo so a lot of
automotive companies are switching over
to much more graphic and flat icons and
people are having a problem with that
okay so Omar's pulling up his file here
so Omar the the business card at the top
right that's what I want you to work on
yeah so if you can pull into that any
other questions mark that yeah there was
a question here people are asking about
how to present the brand story how much
of that to include in the deck and where
I guess it depends on audience and what
you're presenting
yeah not totally yeah I think the
question its it has to do with when
they're presenting the logo to the
client yeah how much do you talk about
the brand story you know in that
transition of the redesign and where do
you put that in the deck okay okay all
right
Omar looks like he's a little confused
as to what he needs to do I'm gonna
answer our question one second so Omar
do you know what you're doing what I'm
asking you to do question for me no no I
I'm I just want to make sure while we're
answering questions that you you tried
is one thing for me
right work on the other side of the
business card not this side the other
one yeah the back side sleeve yeah that
one the blue one okay okay yes so all I
want you do is take service and MVP and
move it up leave the guy where he's at
and just move it up okay no no BP leave
the icon where that yeah and you select
them and separate them okay no you can
rasterize it move it up smart object
right just separate those two things and
move service and yeah there you go
just move that out please okay while
you're doing that so perfect okay so
I'll focus on this first before so go
ahead and move that up okay move it up a
little bit more so that this pips what
we want to do is you know the the space
between service the word and MVP I want
that to line up with where the arrow is
supposed to be right like where his arm
is move it down a little bit it's a
little bit high for me yeah somewhere
right around there yeah there you go you
see how that's a continuation of his arm
and implies kind of like some movement
there that's just for my taste and the
internet now can tell me everybody's
watching this did I make it worse
because sometimes I can do that or is it
better you guys let me know but I
actually like this quite a bit it's a
nice lock up and it
kind of creates a nice horizontal shape
for me and it moves right okay
now let's answer their whole brains
story I think what we we don't get to
see a lot in the logo therapy sessions
is how we're actually working with
clients when you're working with a
client it's not supposed to be like give
me my money and I'm gonna disappear for
three months in my cave and I'm gonna
make something I'm gonna come back and
tell you all these wonderful things
about your brand that you didn't know
it's supposed to be a process that we do
together we're supposed to work in
conjunction like this so there isn't a
brand story to a big brand story to tell
at the end of this because strategically
that should have been worked out already
at the beginning so if you're presenting
the brand story then it's not necessary
for the client or the customer it's
maybe for their team people were not
involved in the big decisions that
they're being made and potentially
because you're using this to onboard new
clients so we kinda have to be very
clear are we doing this for the client
and the people were going to use the
system or are we doing it to get new
customers and so you may change or craft
the story differently depending on what
your end goal is okay usually what you
want to do is you want to talk about the
brand story upfront about who we are as
a company our beliefs our vision mission
and values those kinds of things and
what our history looks like and why
we're moving forward with this thing if
you ever want to learn how to tell the
story of the creation of a mark or a log
or identity system go find online
Paul rands books here he's famous for
putting together elaborate presentations
for big logo redesigns like I think
there was one for the morning star or
something like that
our morning Sun and he would go through
and show the client all the logical
design decisions he made from start to
finish another one that he did that you
guys may may remember is the next logo
which is Steve Jobs company after he was
booted out of Apple next computers check
that out like the decisions that are
made there it's really good okay same
thing for IBM you can see his whole
thinking process and it's very logical
all the decisions he's made to arrive at
the final solution okay
having said that Omar is anything else
that you want to talk about you're good
okay are there any and the last
remaining lingering questions mark no
[Laughter]
its Cuomo Andrew Cuomo interviewing each
other he's like have you ever consider
for running for president no would you
ever think about no but how do you know
this cuz I know okay Omar I'm gonna
thank you on behalf of everybody that's
tuning in and I hope this encourages
some of you young designers who may not
get enough attention or spotlight to
keep at your craft one day if you keep
working on this somebody will notice
maybe will notice I don't know and we'll
put you on the show so feel free to
reach out to me on the internet and
share with me a logo that you want to
redesign show me before and after and if
I like it and if you have your
audiovisual game up to snuff we'll have
you on the show as simple as that okay
so on behalf of everybody I got to
switch to this this is the original logo
this is the revised logo this is from
young Omar Soliman who's based out of
Ankara Turkey but he's originally from
Iraq go check him out I think his
Behance name is Omar three to four yes
three to four Omar three to four and
with that you guys I'm taking us off the
show thanks very much
don't forget to like on you guys
[Music]